This is 99% Invisible. I'm Kurt Colstead. Okay, so, like, what I want you to do is, I want you to take a breath, take a breath, okay? And just, like, you know, just get into your voice a little bit and go, this is 99% invisible. I'm Kurt Colstead. This is 99% invisible. I'm Kurt Colstead. Okay.
这是 99% Invisible。我是库尔特·科尔斯特德。好吧，所以，比如说，我希望你做的是，我希望你做个深呼吸，做个深呼吸，好吗？然后就像，你知道的，稍微进入你的声音状态，然后说，这里是 99% Invisible。我是库尔特·科尔斯特德。这里是 99% Invisible。我是库尔特·科尔斯特德。好。
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I want you to do it again. Okay. And I want you to do it now this time, like, I want you to do, the gravitas is there. Like, you're getting like that part of the tone. But I want you to add, now that you have that, I want you to add like a little bit of smile in your voice. Okay. Okay. So you're going to go, this is 99% invisible.
不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，我希望你再来一次。好。我希望你现在再做一次，就像，我希望你做到，那种庄严感要出来。就像，你正在抓那种语调。但我希望你加上，既然你已经有了那种感觉，我希望你在声音里加入一点微笑。好。好。所以你要说，这里是 99% Invisible。
I'm Kurt Kolstad. This is 99% invisible. I'm Kurt Kolstead. That's great. I love it. Print it. In 2020, my co-author, Roman Mars, and I, put out a hit book about the built environment. It's an illustrated hardcover we called A Field Guide to the Hidden World of Everyday Design.
我是库尔特·科尔斯特德。这里是 99% Invisible。我是库尔特·科尔斯特德。太棒了。我很喜欢。就这么定。在 2020 年，我和我的合著者罗曼·马尔斯推出了一本关于人造环境的畅销书。这是一本带插图的精装书，我们将其命名为《日常设计的隐藏世界野外指南》。
The 99% Invisible City was an instant New York Times bestseller and top the charts in the UK, Canada, and Australia. Versions of the book were also released in other countries as well, translated into languages including Spanish, Czech, Chinese, Korean, and Japanese. In the years since these first edition releases, Kurt and I have worked together on a number of new episodes and many stories with an eye towards an eventual second edition, a kind of revised and expanded paperback iteration with additional, as yet unprinted stories. But today, rather than wait on publishers or printers, we've decided to share a set of four of our favorite short stories from the past half decade, each of which corresponds to one of the four main chapters of the 99% Invisible City. And those chapters are infrastructure, urbanism, geography, and architecture. So if you enjoy what follows, be sure to check out both the book, the 99% Invisible City, and the original episodes associated with each short story. That's right. Let's get started.
《99% Invisible City》一经出版便登上《纽约时报》畅销书榜，并荣登英国、加拿大和澳大利亚的排行榜榜首。该书的各个版本也在其他国家发行，被翻译成西班牙语、捷克语、中文、韩语和日语等多种语言。自这些首版发行以来的几年里，库尔特和我一直合作制作许多新剧集和许多故事，着眼于最终的推出第二版，这是一种修订和扩充的平装版迭代，包含更多尚未印刷的故事。但今天，与其等待出版商或印刷厂，我们决定分享过去五年中我们最喜欢的四个短篇故事，每一个都对应着《99% Invisible City》的四个主要章节之一。这些章节是：基础设施、城市规划、地理和建筑。所以，如果你喜欢接下来的内容，请务必查看这本书《99% Invisible City》，以及与每个短篇故事相关的原创剧集。没错。让我们开始吧。
Infrastructure. Shortly before the book came out, but after the final draft was already locked in, Roman and I did an episode on Roadway Signs and other Roadway Infrastructure Designs. We titled it Highways 101. And what started us down this road was a letter from a fan. One of the things Kurt does is he checks our inbox for listeners submitted ideas, combs through all of them. And earlier this summer, a 99PI fan named Daniel wrote us about a strange stop sign
基础设施。就在这本书出版前不久，但在最终初稿已经敲定之后，罗曼和我制作了一集关于道路标志和其他道路基础设施设计的节目。我们给它起名为“高速公路 101”。而让我们开始关注这一领域的是一位粉丝的来信。库尔特的工作之一就是检查我们的收件箱，寻找听众提交的想法，并筛选所有这些想法。今年夏天早些时候，一个 99PI 的粉丝名叫丹尼尔的给我们写信，讲述了一个奇怪的停车标志。
that he encountered while traveling. And you started digging into this story. Yeah, so his email started like this. A couple of years ago, we took a trip to Hawaii. my wife became obsessed over a few blue stop signs we saw in parking lots. The signs were the size and shape and used the same lettering as normal red stop signs, but they were bright blue. So I don't think I've ever seen that before.
他在旅行时遇到了。而你开始深入研究这个故事。是的，所以他的电子邮件是这样开头的：几年前，我们去夏威夷旅行。我妻子对我们在停车场看到的几个蓝色停车标志着迷了。这些标志的大小、形状和普通红色停车标志使用相同的字体，但它们是亮蓝色的。所以我想我以前从来没有见过这个。
I had never seen this either, either in images or in real life. So I started looking into why some were blue, and that turned out to be pretty easy to figure out. But it got me wondering something a lot more fundamental, which is, why are the rest of them all red? Right? Exactly. Why is that such a thing in the first place?
我以前也从未见过这个，无论是在图片中还是在现实生活中。所以我开始研究为什么有些是蓝色的，结果发现这很容易弄清楚。但这让我开始思考一个更根本的问题，那就是，为什么剩下的全都是红色的？对吧？没错。为什么一开始会有这种现象？
Totally. Yeah. And that got me into, of course, digging into the whole history of stop signs. Of course. Of course. That's the only way this is going to go with you. Yeah. It's just my nature.
完全是这样。是的，这让我开始深入研究停车标志的整个历史。当然。当然。这也就是你研究这件事唯一的进行方式了。是的。这就是我的天性。
And as I was looking into this, this one figure kept popping up everywhere I looked. A guy named William Phelps Eno, who in the early 1900s became known as the father of traffic safety. Oh. Okay. So what do you have to do to earn that title? father of traffic safety. So, Eno was born way back in the 1850s. And if you think about it, you know, 1850s, he's in New York. This is in New York without cars. Right. So, of course, it's in New York without stop signs. That stop signs, totally. Yeah. The roads back then were kind
当我研究这个问题时，这个人物在我看过的所有地方不断出现。一个名叫威廉·菲尔普斯·埃诺的人，他在 20 世纪初被称为交通安全之父。哦。好吧。那么你必须做什么才能赢得这个称号呢？交通安全之父。所以，埃诺早在 19 世纪 50 年代就出生了。如果你想想看，你知道的，18 世纪 50 年代，他在纽约。这是没有汽车的纽约。对。所以，当然，这是没有停车标志的纽约。有停车标志，完全是的。那时的道路有点。
of this open space that was shared by carriages and pedestrians and they moved all around. It was a lot different. Right, right. It wasn't very organized. More and more people were on the streets and, you know, cars started showing up. Right. And it just was included. increasingly clear that this was a mess and it was going to need some kind of regulation. And so was Eno some kind of road expert? Is that what he was working on? Well, that's the thing. Not really. He came from this family real estate business, decided it wasn't for him. It wasn't his passion. His passion was traffic. So in 1900, he writes this article. And it's not entirely clear in hindsight if he realized what he was doing at the time,
这种开放空间是马车和行人共用的，他们四处走动。情况大不相同。对，对。它不是很井然有序。越来越多的人走上街头，而且，你知道的，汽车开始出现。对。而且很明显，这是一团糟，需要某种形式的规制。那么，埃诺是某种道路专家吗？这就是他一直在做的事情吗？嗯，这就是关键所在。其实不然。他出身于房地产家族企业，觉得这不适合他。这不是他的激情所在。他的激情是交通。所以在 1900 年，他写了这篇文章。事后看来，当时他是否意识到自己在做什么并不是完全清楚，
but he basically was writing a treatise that would lay the groundwork for everything he would do for the rest of his life. So in the end, he would come around to, you know, inventing and evolving all different kinds of traffic innovations, things we take for granted today, like rotary junctions and pedestrian crossings. Wow. So he really earned that title, the father of traffic safety. Absolutely. And once his ideas got some traction in the U.S., he began helping other cities create traffic plans. And some really recognizable designs trace back to him, like roundabouts at Piccadilly Circus in London and around the Arc to Triumph in Paris. And he was even inducted into the Legion of Honor by the French government after World War I. For traffic? Yes. Like that's what
但他基本上是在撰写一份奠基性的论文，为他余生所做的一切奠定了基础。所以最后，他会开始发明和发展各种不同的交通创新，比如我们今天认为理所当然的事情，如环形路口和人行横道。哇。所以他真的赢得了那个称号，交通安全之父。绝对的。一旦他的想法在美国得到了一些关注，他就开始帮助其他城市制定交通计划。一些真正容易辨认的设计都可以追溯到他，比如伦敦皮卡迪利广场的环岛和巴黎凯旋门周围的环岛。甚至在第一次世界大战后，他还被法国政府授予荣誉军团勋章。为了交通？是的。就像那是他
he got that. Wow. And so was Eno the man who invented the stop sign? Well, that's the thing. I kind of filed down this rabbit hole, looking into him. But one thing I realized along the way was that I was never going to find the inventor of the stop sign. Because it's one of those things that has existed in various forms for a while now. But it's safe to say that Eno played a really big role in popularizing stop signs and yield signs and that kind of signage infrastructure. And also, you know, put this in context, right?
因此获得的。哇。那么埃诺是发明停车标志的人吗？嗯，就是这样。我顺着这个兔子洞找下去，研究了他。但我沿途意识到的一件事是，我永远找不到停车标志的发明者。因为它是那种以各种形式存在了一段时间的事物之一。但可以肯定的是，埃诺在普及停车标志、让行标志和这类标牌基础设施方面发挥了非常大的作用。而且，你知道，把这个放在大背景下看，对吧？
Stop signs back then, they weren't what we think. think of as stop signs today. Their designs varied from place to place. One of the first ones that popped up in Detroit in, I think it was 1915, had black lettering on a white background, presumably be for contrast. So they really, they came in all these different shapes and sizes, and there was no sort of one person you could say, aha, that guy made the stop sign. Yeah, I mean, I think that makes sense to me, that there would be a need for stop signs, and therefore they would be invented in multiple places and multiple. times. So when did they sort of get this octagonal shape that we attribute to them? Like,
那时的停车标志，它们不是我们今天想的那种停车标志。它们的设计因地制宜。1915 年左右出现在底特律的第一批停车标志之一，在白色背景上有黑色字体，大概是为了形成对比。所以它们真的，它们有各种不同的形状和大小，没有哪一个人可以说是，啊哈，那家伙制作了停车标志。是的，我的意思是，我认为这对我来说是有道理的，会有对停车标志的需求，因此它们会在多个地方和多次被发明出来。那么它们是什么时候开始呈现出我们归因于它们的八角形形状的呢？就像，
when did that happen? Right. So that one actually does have a specific answer. And the answer is 1923. That's when the Mississippi Valley Association of State Highway Departments decided to standardize the shape. That's a very specific answer. Yes. Yeah. And it was a pretty good idea to make it non-standard shape, something that would stand out. But there was actually more to it than that. They had this idea that they could create an association between geometry and safety. Explain more of what you mean there. Well, they believed that the shape itself could communicate something. Like, part of what the sign was trying to do could be achieved through the shape of that sign.
那是什么时候发生的？对。所以那个实际上有一个具体的答案。答案是 1923 年。也就是密西西比州公路部门协会决定统一形状的时候。这是一个非常具体的答案。是的。是的。把形状做成非标准的、能让人一眼认出的东西，是个相当不错的想法。但实际上还有更多的原因。他们当时有一个想法，就是可以在几何形状和安全之间建立某种联系。请多解释一下你这里的意思。嗯，他们相信形状本身可以传达一些信息。也就是说，标志试图实现的一部分功能可以通过该标志的形状来实现。
Okay. So we're not talking about just associating a. rare shape with a specific meaning. There's some kind of theory behind eight having a meaning that ties to stopping. Yes. And this was a huge surprise to me. Yeah, because it sounds like nonsense. It sounds right. It sounds sort of occult almost, right? Totally. But I found this out through this New York Times Magazine article by Hillary Greenbaum and Dana Rubenstein. And I'm just going to have you read this excerpt for context that explains why the Highway Department's Association recommended different shapes for different signs. Okay, here it is. Quote, the recommendations were based on a simple, albeit not exactly intuitive idea. The more sides a sign has, the higher
好的。所以我们谈论的不仅仅是将一个罕见的形状与特定含义联系起来。这里面存在某种理论，即数字“8”具有与停车相关的含义。是的。这对我来说是一个巨大的惊喜。是的，因为听起来像无稽之谈。听起来很对。听起来几乎有点神秘主义色彩，对吧？完全是。但我通过希拉里·格林鲍姆（Hillary Greenbaum）和达娜·鲁宾斯坦（Dana Rubenstein）在《纽约时报杂志》上的一篇文章发现了这一点。为了让大家了解背景，我将请你朗读这段摘录，它解释了为什么公路部门协会建议对不同的标志采用不同的形状。好的，在这里。引述：“这些建议基于一个简单却并非完全符合直觉的想法：标志的边数越多，它所代表的
the danger level it invokes. By the engineer's reckoning, the circle, which has an infinite number of sides, screamed danger and was recommended for railroad crossings. the octagon with its eight sides was used to denote the second highest level the diamond shape was for warning signs and the rectangle in square shapes were used for informational signs end quote that is just wild it really is right i mean there's so many things that i have so many questions i have about this and one of which is like it's a circle really have an infinite number of sides well yeah so i'm thinking back to like you know grade school geometry and i'm like i mean i think that there's something to that I think it's like, yeah, if you take the tangent of each point and therefore it has an infinite number of signs, but I don't think people perceive it as having infinite number of sides. I think they perceive it as having one side. Right. It's not like we look at a circle, a square, and a triangle, and we say, aha, right. Three, four, and infinite signs. It never in a million years occurred to me that there was some grand geometric theory behind U.S. stop sign shapes. But if you think about it, if you start to unpack it and you look. at signs around you, you can sort of understand what they're getting at, right? It's like,
危险等级就越高。根据工程师的计算，拥有无限多边形的圆圈发出了危险的信号，因此被推荐用于铁路交叉口；拥有八条边的八角形被用来表示第二高等级；菱形用于警告标志；而长方形和正方形则用于信息标志。”引述结束。这真是太疯狂了！确实如此，对吧？我的意思是，关于这个我有太多的问题，其中一个就是，圆圈真的有无限多条边吗？嗯，是的，所以我回想起像，你知道的，小学几何，我想，我的意思是，我认为这有一定道理。我认为就像，是的，如果你取每个点的切线，因此它有无限多条边，但我不认为人们认为它有无限多条边。我认为他们认为它只有一条边。对。我们不会看到一个圆圈、一个正方形和一个三角形，然后说，啊哈，对吧？三条边、四条边和无限条边。我做梦也没有想到美国停车标志的形状背后还有什么宏大的几何理论。但如果你仔细想想，如果你开始剖析它并观察你周围的标志，你就能大致理解他们的意图，对吧？就像是，
well, yeah, rectangular signs often tell you, like, what exit to take or something. There's circles at railroad crossings, sure. Yeah, but there's also, like, arm bars at railroad crossings, you know, like, because the circle is not quite enough sometimes. There's also exes and arm bars and all kinds of other things. So I get that there's a theory behind it. And if it has some kind of basis and semiotics, I'm willing to entertain that notion. So now that, You know, in 1923, in Mississippi, they established the shape. How did they come up with the red background? Well, that might seem like the simpler decision.
嗯，是的，长方形的标志通常会告诉你，比如说，该从哪个出口出去之类的。铁路交叉口有圆圈，当然。是的，但也有，比如说，铁路交叉口的栏杆，你知道的，因为有时候圆圈还不够。还有交叉口、栏杆和各种其他东西。所以我明白它背后是有理论的。如果它在符号学上有某种基础，我愿意接受这种观点。所以既然，你知道，在 1923 年的密西西比州，他们确立了这种形状。他们是怎么想出红色背景的呢？嗯，这可能看起来是一个更简单的决定。
That would actually took a while longer. At the time, yellow was often used, in part just for material science reasons. Like, they couldn't get a really good, reflective, durable red. And so yellow showed up while at night. So for decades, that was the general standard. And then in the 1950s, they made red the official standard. Okay, so yellow because you can make kind of a matte yellow and it contrasts really well with black, for example, when it looks really good at night. But until you get that shiny red that you see on a stop sign, red is not a very good stop sign color.
这实际上花了更长的时间。当时经常使用黄色，部分原因只是出于材料科学的原因。例如，他们无法获得真正具有反射性、经久耐耐用的红色。因此，黄色在夜间显现出来。因此，几十年来，这一直是总体标准。然后在 20 世纪 50 年代，他们将红色定为官方标准。好的，所以用黄色是因为你可以做出一种哑光黄色，而且它与黑色形成了很好的对比，例如，在夜间看起来非常好。但在你得到停车标志上看到的那种闪亮的红色之前，红色并不是一个很好的停车标志颜色。
Right. And if you think about like, when you see a red stop sign at night, it is really shiny and really reflective. And also, by that time, too, you know, we've got stoplights and other signage. And red has really got this. built-up association of being a thing telling you to stop. So making them red just kind of fit with the grander scheme of everything else that was going out at the time. Yeah, and it's a warning color in nature. I suppose yellow is too, but yeah, it makes sense. So how does this, you know, get us to those blue stop signs in Hawaii that Daniel found? Oh, right. And that's how we come full circle or full octagon, as it were. And it turns out the blue-painted stop. And it turns out the blue-painted stop signs are actually exceptional on purpose. You usually find them on private property,
对。如果你想想，当你晚上看到一个红色的停车标志时，它是真的很闪亮，反光效果很好。而且，到那个时候，你知道，我们已经有了红绿灯和其他标牌。红色确实已经建立了一种让人联想到“停”的关联。所以把它们做成红色，恰好符合当时正在进行的宏大计划。是的，而且它在自然界中是一种警告色。我想黄色也是，但是的，这说得通。那么，这怎么能把我们引向丹尼尔在夏威夷发现的那些蓝色停车标志呢？哦，对了。这就是我们如何绕了一大圈，或者说是绕了一个八边形。事实证明，画成蓝色的停车标志。事实证明，画成蓝色的停车标志实际上是特意为之的。你通常在私人财产上找到它们，
places like store parking lots, and the reason they're blue is so they won't be confused with other official government red signs. That makes sense. So they're like intentional fakes because they don't want it to seem like it's a sign maintained by the city or county. So they're like mall cops. They have a badge. They might have a gun, but they're not actual cops. Yeah, right. Like whether you actually decide to pay attention to what the sign's telling you is a little bit up to you. But it is really clear what it's trying to tell you, right? Yeah, I mean, that's one of the things I think that's so great about the stop sign is that with the shape, the word stop, and the color, you can really take one or two of those elements
比如商店停车场，它们之所以是蓝色的，是为了不与政府其他官方的红色标志混淆。这就说得通了。所以它们就像是有意制造的假货，因为他们不想让它看起来像是城市或县维护的标志。所以它们就像是商场保安。他们有徽章。他们可能有枪，但他们不是真正的警察。是的，对吧。至于你实际上是否决定听从标志告诉你的内容，这有点取决于你自己。但它试图告诉你什么非常清楚，对吧？是的，我的意思是，这是我认为停车标志如此伟大的原因之一，凭借其形状，“停”这个字和颜色，你真的可以采用其中一个或两个元素
and at this point, it'll convey the meaning. Like if you had a red octagon with no word stop on it, I think people would generally stop. Right. Or if you saw, you know, an octagon from behind. you'll know that that's a stop sign. The other people have to stop, yeah, totally. Yeah. You know, that's a good sign. So they were onto something in Mississippi in 1923, and they figured something out.
在这一点上，它传达了含义。就像如果你有一个上面没有“停”字的红色八角形，我认为人们通常会停下来。对。或者如果你看到，你知道的，一个背面的八角形。你会知道那是一个停车标志。其他人必须停下来，是的，完全。是的。你知道，那是个好标志。所以他们在 1923 年的密西西比州是有所发现的，他们弄明白了某些东西。
Urbanism. During the COVID pandemic, I became interested in how other global disasters had historically impacted urban design. And my research yielded not. only stories of white-knuckled perseverance and resiliency as you'd expect, but also tenacious creativity and playful innovation. So I pitched Roman on a Horseman of the Apocalypse themed episode titled War, Famine, Pestilence, and Design. And that might all sound very serious, and a lot of it is, but, and that's when I came across the rise of miniature golf during the Great Depression of all times.
城市规划。在新冠疫情大流行期间，我开始对历史上其他全球灾难如何影响城市设计产生兴趣。我的研究不仅带来了意料之中的白炽般的坚韧和复原力的故事，还带来了顽强的创造力和好玩的创新。因此，我向罗曼推销了一个以“末日四骑士”为主题的节目，名为“战争、饥荒、瘟疫和设计”。这一切听起来可能非常严肃，其中很多也确实如此，但是，正是在那时，我偶然发现了迷你高尔夫在大萧条时期异军突起的故事。
That is not an association I would have made. So when I picture miniature golf courses, I kind of think of like the World War II era, you know, like sort of kitschy leisure and baby boomers and that kind of thing, not the Great Depression. Yeah, right. I mean, the last thing on your mind when you look at a mini golf course is the worst economic crash in modern history. So did mini golf come up because like it was too expensive to maintain?
这不是我会建立的联系。所以当我脑海中浮现出迷你高尔夫球场时，我有点联想到二战时期的那种感觉，你知道的，就像那种有点媚俗的休闲活动、婴儿潮一代以及诸如此类的事情，而不是大萧条。是的，对吧。我的意思是，当你看着一个迷你高尔夫球场时，你脑海中浮现的最后一件事就是现代历史上最严重的经济崩溃。那么迷你高尔夫的出现是因为维护成本太高吗？
you know, big fancy golf courses or something like that? I mean, that's part of it, right? There's no way you're going to maintain these huge grounds for just a couple people walking along with their golf clubs. And like all that we associate with sort of luxurious sprawling golf courses, that was kind of not on the agenda financially. But also, there's just the matter of space, right? You've got all these people who are in cities and need something to do.
你知道的，那些大型豪华高尔夫球场之类的？我的意思是，这是部分原因，对吧？你绝不可能仅仅为了几个带着高尔夫球杆散步的人去维护这些巨大的场地。所有那些我们联想到的那种奢侈的、绵延数英里高尔夫球场的东西，在财务上根本不在考虑之列。但同时，这也只是空间问题，对吧？你有所有这些身处城市却需要找点事情做的人。
And, you know, they don't have transportation to get out of cities. So mini golf becomes this kind of logical, solution, kind of infill solution in the urban environment. Right. So like along with everything else, real estate prices plunged and there's some space and you might, you know, if you have a little bit of space, you can build, you know, a miniature golf course. Yeah, that's exactly it. The conditions were in some ways totally ideal in the wake of 1929 for exactly this kind of activity. And so while technically mini golf actually predates the stock market collapse, the crisis really ramped up interest in And you have, as you noted, like tons of closed businesses and vacant lots, and, you know, all of this is just ripe for entrepreneurs to take over.
而且，你知道，他们没有交通工具离开城市。所以迷你高尔夫就成了这种合乎逻辑的解决方案，一种城市环境中的填充式解决方案。对。就像其他一切一样，房地产价格暴跌，有一些空间，你可能会，你知道的，如果你有一小块空间，你就可以建造一个迷你高尔夫球场。是的，完全是这样。在 1929 年之后，在某些方面，这种环境绝对是开展此类活动的理想条件。因此，虽然从技术上讲，迷你高尔夫的出现实际上早于股市崩盘，但危机确实加剧了人们对它的兴趣。正如你所指出的，你有大量的倒闭企业和空置地块，而且，你知道的，所有这些都正是企业家接手的好时机。
And even in places where there's not extra space, people just kind of made space. Like, they would convert rooftops into pee-wee golf courses or parking lots, really anything. And so it was this surprisingly huge fad. And at one point, somebody even called it the madness of the 1930s. Specifically talking about miniature pee-wee-gall. is the madness in this phrase. Absolutely insanity. That's quite the sequel to the roaring 20s.
甚至在没有额外空间的地方，人们也会自己腾出空间。例如，他们会把屋顶改造成儿童迷你高尔夫球场或停车场，真的什么都可以。所以这是一种令人惊讶的巨大风靡。有一度，甚至有人称之为 20 世纪 30 年代的疯狂。特指迷你儿童高尔夫。这其中的疯狂。绝对的疯狂。这真不愧是咆哮的二十年代的续集啊。
Yeah. And so you've got these two very different periods in a way, but there's also this parallel where if you think about it, everybody needs recreation and distraction. And it doesn't matter if things are going well or they're going horribly. And given the economic situation in the 30s, cheaper activities were naturally much more appealing. So on the business side, it's also an opportunity. right? Because people could turn their own yards into courses or the interiors of their unused office buildings. Basically, anybody could try their hand at building a course. And so
是的。所以从某种意义上说，你有这两个非常不同的时期，但这也存在着一种相似性，如果你想想看，每个人都需要娱乐和消遣。无论事情进展顺利还是糟糕透顶，这都不重要。鉴于 30 年代的经济形势，更便宜的活动自然更具吸引力。所以在商业方面，这也是一个机会，对吧？因为人们可以把自己的院子变成球场，或者把他们未使用的办公楼内部改成球场。基本上，任何人都可以尝试建造一个球场。所以
tons of people did. Wow, I love picturing that, the people just entrepreneurally, like setting up a miniature golf course, like a lemonade stand, like everywhere they can. So when did all the things that I think of when it comes to miniature golf crop up, like the, you know, the mechanical windmills or the ramps and, you know, all that sort of stuff? Wouldn't that happen? So some of the more technologically advanced stuff came later. But a lot of those basic things that we still see in miniature golf courses today do date back to this exact era. Things like ramps and bridges and ridges, people just build out of like available dirt or whatever they could find. And at the same time, you have this recent invention of artificial turf, which helps courses hold up better to foot traffic,
无数人这么做了。哇，我喜欢想象那个画面，人们只是凭着企业家的精神，像开柠檬水摊一样，尽可能在任何地方建立一个迷你高尔夫球场。那么，当我想到迷你高尔夫时想到的那些东西，比如机械风车、坡道以及所有诸如此类的东西，是什么时候突然出现的呢？难道那不是后来发生的吗？所以一些技术含量更高的是后来才出现的。但我们在今天的迷你高尔夫球场上仍然看到的许多基本东西确实可以追溯到这个确切的时代。像坡道、桥梁和山脊这样的东西，人们只是用现有的泥土或他们能找到的任何东西搭建起来。与此同时，你有了最近发明的人造草皮，它有助于球场更好地经受住行人的践踏，
so people who could afford it would add that to make a more robust course. But, you know, really the kind of key in all this is all the odds and ants. Coursemakers could just grab whatever scraps they could find, pipes and stones and just work them into this bigger design. And there was some scrappy entrepreneurialism in picking the sites for these places, too. Like, some would situate their courses underneath big lit-up billboards so that they could operate at night without having to pay for, you know, the light bulbs or the electricity. Oh, I love it.
所以那些买得起的人会添加这个来建造一个更坚固的球场。但是，你知道，这里面真正的关键是所有那些零星的小物件。球场建造者可以抓起他们能找到的任何边角料，管道和石头，然后将它们融入到这个更大的设计中。在为这些地方选址时，也有一些精明创业的做法，对吧。例如，有些人会将他们的球场建在大型发光广告牌下面，这样他们就可以在夜间营业，而不必支付灯泡或电费。哦，我太喜欢了。
This is so fun to picture. like cities filled with miniature golf courses everywhere. I mean, am I getting this right? Is it really like everywhere? Yeah, I mean, I've literally seen pictures of it being everywhere. And like I love these images of like little rooftops that are where people are crowded around like playing mini golf. And, you know, it's totally the opposite of what we can imagine today, right? Like you look at New York City and you think, well, every bit of real estate is used and expensive.
想象这个画面太有趣了。就像城市里到处都是迷你高尔夫球场。我的意思是，我理解对了吗？真的是到处都是吗？是的，我的意思是，我真的见过到处都是的照片。我喜欢这些小屋顶的画面，人们挤在上面打迷你高尔夫。而且，这完全是我们今天无法想象的，对吧？就像你看纽约市，你会想，每一处房地产都被利用了而且很贵。
But back then it was like, no, there were little spaces you could cram into. And so people would just head out in droves and go play mini golf. Wow. I mean, minigolf is delightful, so it doesn't surprise me all that much. But the ubiquity of it that you're describing really is striking. Yeah. And, of course, with all these creators vying to make their course the best course, trying to attract, you know, more players, there was innovation around that, too,
但在那个时候就像是，不，有你可以塞进去的小空间。所以人们会蜂拥而出，去打迷你高尔夫。哇。我的意思是，迷你高尔夫很讨人喜欢，所以它并不让我感到太惊讶。但你所描述的那种无处不在的现象确实令人震惊。是的，当然，随着所有这些创造者竞相把他们的球场做得最好，试图吸引更多的球员，周围也出现了创新，
like ways that people would try to set there's apart. Things like pools and mazes and traps popped up. and eventually more kind of fancy things like fountains and forests and castles and even replicas of famous architecture like the Taj Mahal or the great well of china and so over time these things become almost like tiny theme parks right like just populated with all kinds of wild and creative and colorful stuff and this one in particular that i read about i think has my personal favorite feature which is a trained monkey that goes after your ball so if you're not careful careful. It'll just come and snatch your ball and it's like game over. I would definitely go to that park. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I wish that one was still around today. But a lot of the elements are still around, right? Like those complex courses with the miniature architecture, it's like become a kind of staple and it's still like this thing that we associate with like a fun family night out.
比如人们试图脱颖而出的方式。诸如游泳池、迷宫和陷阱之类的东西纷纷涌现。最后是更多类似喷泉、森林、城堡甚至泰姬陵或中国万里长城等著名建筑复制品的花哨东西。所以随着时间的推移，这些东西几乎变成了微型主题公园，对吧？里面充斥着各种疯狂、富有创意和丰富多彩的东西。我读到的这个特别的公园，我认为有我个人最喜欢的特色，那就是一只训练有素的猴子，它会追你的球。所以如果你不小心。它就会过来抢走你的球，这就好比游戏结束了。我绝对会去那个公园。哦，是的。是的。我希望那个公园今天仍然存在。但许多元素仍然存在，对吧？就像那些带有微型建筑的复杂球场，它已经成为了一种主打项目，并且仍然是我们联想到的那种愉快的家庭之夜的活动。
Totally. It's just sort of fun to imagine New York City just being carpeted with miniature golf course, is of all things. I just, I kind of love it. Oh, I do too. I do too. Geography 99% Invisible has a recurring episode series we call MapQuests. Each new installment collects geography related stories from different producers. In some cases, a given collection might revolve around a specific place or typology, and one such set named 5440 or fight came out during the COVID era, and it contains a set of stories centered on the border between the United States and our country's affable neighbor to the north.
完全是。想象一下纽约市到处都是迷你高尔夫球场，这真是太有趣了。我只是，我有点喜欢它。哦，我也是！我也是！地理。99% Invisible 有一个名为“地图任务”（MapQuests）的常设剧集系列。每一个新分集都收集了来自不同制作人的与地理相关的故事。在某些情况下，给定的收藏可能围绕某个特定的地方或类型展开，其中一个名为“5440 或战斗”（5440 or fight）的系列在新冠疫情期间问世，它包含了一组以美国与我们北方温和的邻国之间的边界为中心的故事。
And you have a Canadian border story for us? Oh, I do. Okay, hit me. It's about this pair of adjacent parks that are along the U.S. Canadian border in Blaine, Washington, and Surrey, British Columbia. And in these parks, like, right where they meet along the border, there's this big, Peace Arch Monument with this inscription, May these gates never be closed.
你有一个关于加拿大边境的故事吗？哦，有的。好的，说来听听。它是关于华盛顿州布莱恩和不列颠哥伦比亚省萨里市美加边境沿线的一对相邻公园的。在这些公园里，就在它们沿边界交汇的地方，有一座巨大的和平拱门纪念碑，上面刻着铭文：“愿这些大门永远不要关闭。”
Wow. Well, that's a pretty bold statement for a border. Right. Which seems like antithetical to what borders are usually about. So what's the story there? Well, the arch and the parks date back to the early 1900s, but that never closed sentiment is actually a nod to the war of 1812 between the U.S. and the U.K. And at the end of that conflict, basically both sides signed a treaty. to leave the border between the U.S. and Canada undefended as a sign of friendship.
哇。好吧，这对于一个边境来说是一个相当大胆的声明。对。这似乎与边境通常的意义背道而驰。那么背后的故事是什么？嗯，这座拱门和公园可以追溯到 20 世纪初，但“永不关闭”这种情感实际上是对美英 1812 年战争的一种致敬。在那场冲突结束时，基本上双方都签署了一项条约。将美加边界设为不设防状态，以此作为友谊的象征。
And so now there's this arch with this sentiment written on it, but can you truly walk through it whenever you want? Well, yeah, for most of the past century, you absolutely could. And when this park space is open for visitors, people can just freely cross into it from either side and then hang out without actually waiting to get through some tedious border checkpoint. So it ends up being this kind of no man's land. And then when they leave, visitors just have to exit back to their country of origin. Okay. So the arch doesn't really operate as a checkpoint. But it sounds as if the entrance to each park might operate as
所以现在有一座刻有这种情感的拱门，但你真的可以随时随地穿过它吗？嗯，是的，在过去的整整一个世纪里，你绝对可以。当这个公园空间对游客开放时，人们可以从任一侧自由进入，然后聚在一起，而无需实际排队等待通过一些繁琐的边境检查站。所以它最终变成了这样一种“三不管”地带。然后当他们离开时，游客只需返回他们的原籍国。好的。所以这座拱门实际上并不作为检查站运作。但听起来每个公园的入口可能像是一个
checkpoint a little bit. Well, sort of, it's like you can freely walk into the park. Okay. And there's people patrolling the park. But the real key is you should have, identification with you, because when we try to exit the park, like, they want to make sure that you're coming back into the country you're supposed to be coming back into. Yeah. Okay. That makes sense. That makes sense.
小小的检查站。嗯，有点像，你可以自由地走进公园。好的。公园里有人在巡逻。但真正的关键是，你应该随身携带身份证件，因为当我们试图离开公园时，他们想确保你回到了你应该回到的国家。是的。好吧。这说得通。这说得通。
But it's a little less rigorous than what we think of as a normal international border checkpoint. Oh, absolutely. Yeah. Yeah. Cool. But it started to change a little bit on this past year and a half, as you might imagine, because of the pandemic.
但它远没有我们通常认为的国际边境检查站那么严格。哦，绝对是的。是的。是的。酷。但正如你所想象的那样，由于疫情，在过去的这一年半里，情况开始发生了一点变化。
Right. Yeah. So each country maintains and controls its side of the park, right? And early in the pandemic, both sides kept everything. open, but even after Canada decided to close its side down, Canadians have still been able to meet up with Americans by crossing into the U.S. park along this one side. Huh. Well, I could imagine a lot of people are taking advantage of that because everything else was
对。是的。所以每个国家都维护和控制自己那侧的公园，对吧？在疫情初期，双方都保持了一切。开放，但即使在加拿大决定关闭其一侧之后，加拿大人仍然能够通过沿着这一侧进入美国公园来与美国人会面。哼。好吧，我可以想象很多人都在利用这一点，因为其他一切都
pretty closed. Oh, yeah, absolutely. Like, a lot of friends and families split by the border have continued to gather here, and there have even been a ton of binaational weddings at the park. Well, that makes sense. I mean, if it's a convenient way to get it. together and people like get married in parks. Yeah, absolutely.
相当封闭。哦，是的，绝对的。就像，许多被边境分隔的朋友和家人继续在这里聚会，公园里甚至还举办了大量的双国婚礼。这说得通。我的意思是，如果这是一个聚在一起的便捷方式，而且人们喜欢在公园里结婚的话。是的，绝对的。
I don't know what you do after the ceremony. You just split apart again? Yeah, you go your separate ways. I mean, that's the crazy thing, right? It's like you still have to kind of go back to your country of origin. But it's still a pretty convenient place for people to get together and celebrate. Yeah, it's partly that direct ease of access, but also people fully crossing over in conventional ways faced up to a two-week quarantine and COVID testing.
我不知道你在仪式结束后会做什么。你们就各奔东西了吗？是的，你们分道扬镳。我的意思是，这就是疯狂的地方，对吧？就像你仍然必须回到你的原籍国。但对于人们聚在一起庆祝来说，这仍然是一个相当方便的地方。是的，部分原因是这种直接的便利性，但也因为以传统方式完全越境的人面临着长达两周的隔离和新冠检测。
But they can get around all that by meeting up in this. this spot instead. And as you might imagine, you know, divided families who can't afford to take all that time off of work to self-isolate after a trip, I mean, this border zone loophole has been a real boon for them. I'm pretty careful about all the COVID stuff and I think that these quarantines are really, really effective. And I'm just kind of surprised that both countries just haven't shut this down entirely. Yeah. And, you know, that's kind of the craziest part. because legally, no matter what either country wants to do, neither side can fully close the border
但他们可以通过在这个地方聚会来绕过所有这些。正如你所想象的那样，那些无力承担休假进行自我隔离的重重费用的分裂家庭，我的意思是，这个边境地带的漏洞对他们来说真是一大福音。我对所有关于新冠的事情都非常小心，我认为这些隔离措施确实非常非常有效。我只是有点惊讶，为什么两国没有完全关闭这个地方。是的。而且，你知道，这正是最疯狂的部分。因为从法律上讲，无论哪个国家想做什么，任何一方都无法完全关闭边境，
because that would be an international treaty violation. So this is the treaty that you mentioned dating back to the War of 1812. I mean, that thing really has teeth. Like, they have to keep the border open in some place? Yep, that's the idea. Wow. And so you still have authorities policing the parks
因为那将是违反国际条约的行为。所以这就是你提到的可以追溯到 1812 年战争的条约。我的意思是，那个东西真的很有约束力！就像，他们必须在某个地方保持边境开放？是的，就是这个意思。哇。所以你仍然有当局在公园里巡逻，
and, you know, regulating who is allowed in and where they exit. But they're not really able to just stop people from meeting up entirely. Huh. That's kind of amazing. So for the sake of argument, like, what would happen if, you know, one side actually decide to, like, you know, put up a wall and shut the border down? I mean, Canada was pretty proactive when it came to COVID protocols and shutting the border down. Like, what would happen if they put their wall up? Well, that's the thing. I was looking into this, and I found this immigration lawyer who was interviewed by the CBC. And he says that a full closure would have some pretty wild side effects. And it would
而且，你知道的，他们会监管谁被允许进来，以及他们在哪里离开。但他们其实无法完全阻止人们见面。哈。这真是太惊人了。所以为了争论起见，比方说，如果，你知道的，有一方真的决定，呃，你知道的，建一堵墙并关闭边境，会发生什么？我的意思是，加拿大在应对新冠协议和关闭边境方面非常积极。比如说，如果他们建起墙会发生什么？嗯，事情就是这样。我查了一下，我找到了一个接受CBC采访的移民律师。他说，全面关闭会产生一些非常疯狂的副作用。而且这
depend upon which side violates the agreement. Okay. So he claims if Canada broke the treaty, in theory, the U.S. could lay claim to parts of Ontario and Quebec. And if America broke it, Canada could get parts of Maine, Michigan, and Wisconsin. So basically, North American geography, as we know it, is contingent on this early. 1800's treaty remaining in effect. This is just wild. But are people, you know, still kind of worried about meetups, you know, in this park during the pandemic anyway?
将取决于哪一方违反了协议。好吧。所以他声称，如果加拿大打破了条约，理论上美国可以声称拥有安大略省和魁北克省的部分地区。如果美国打破了条约，加拿大可以获得缅因州、密歇根州和威斯康星州的部分地区。所以基本上，我们所知的北美地理取决于19世纪初的这项条约是否继续有效。这太疯狂了。但是人们，你知道的，无论如何还是有点担心在疫情期间这个公园里的聚会吗？
Yeah, no, they do take it really seriously. And there are locals, you know, on both sides who are concerned about COVID from all these visitors, of course, which makes sense. And so a lot comes down to individual visitors. And some of them play it really safe, right? They just sit on their side of the border in chairs. and chat with, like, people from the other side across the border. But, you know, whatever we think or the government thinks about it in terms of health and safety,
是的，不，他们真的很认真对待这件事。当然，当地人，你知道的，双方都有人对所有这些访客带来的新冠病毒感到担忧，这是合乎情理的。所以很多事情归结为个体访客。其中一些人非常谨慎，对吧？他们只是坐在边境自己的一侧的椅子上，和，比如说，另一侧边境的人聊天。但是，你知道的，无论我们或政府在健康和安全方面怎么想，
it just kind of is what it is. Neither side can actually shut it down entirely. At least without, you know, trading parts of Ontario and Maine in the process. Right, except for that. Yeah, exactly. Architecture. For our 500th episode, we produced a three-part series of stories on vernacular architecture, and my contribution to the set covered an ingenious regional roof design, which I learned about from a fan of the show.
事情就是这样。任何一方都无法真正彻底关闭它。至少在没有，你知道的，在此过程中交易安大略省和缅因州的部分地区的情况下。对，除了那个。对，没错。建筑。为了我们的第500期节目，我们制作了一个关于乡土建筑的三部分故事系列，我对这套节目的贡献涵盖了一种巧妙的区域屋顶设计，这是我从节目的一个粉丝那里了解到的。
A while back, I opened an email from a 99PI listener located in Bermuda named Amy Daniels, in which she introduced me to her island's remarkable vernacular architecture. So I wrote back to her to find out more, and the next thing I knew, Amy was introducing me to a local architect. My name is Colin Campbell. I'm a senior architect for OBM in Bermuda. OBM was a firm that started in Bermuda over 85 years ago. And when I asked Colin how he and Amy knew one another, it's Bermuda, his family. Amy asked her mother, and her mother who scratched her head said, oh, I know this fellow. So everything's two degrees of separation.
不久前，我打开了一封来自百慕大99PI听众艾米·丹尼尔斯（Amy Daniels）的电子邮件，她在邮件中向我介绍了她岛上卓越的乡土建筑。所以我给她回信以了解更多信息，接下来的事我知道了，艾米把我介绍给了一位当地建筑师。我叫科林·坎贝尔（Colin Campbell）。我是百慕大OBM的高级建筑师。OBM是一家在百慕大成立85年以上的公司。当我问科林他和艾米是怎么认识的时，这里是百慕大，他的家人。艾米问了她的母亲，她的母亲抓了抓头说，哦，我认识这个人。所以一切都是两度分隔。
Exactly. Yeah. Exactly. Before we got to architecture, I asked Colin to start out by just telling me about Bermuda, which, to be honest, he really sold me on. Bermuda is a place that if it hadn't been made, you couldn't dream it up. It's so crazy, beautiful. It's a little island. It's 22 square miles.
完全正确。是的。完全正确。在我们讨论建筑之前，我请科林先跟我聊聊百慕大，老实说，他真的把我给说动了。百慕大是一个如果你没有亲眼见到，你就梦想不到的地方。它太疯狂、太美丽了。这是一个小岛。它有22平方英里。
It's just on the edge of the Gulf Stream, so we have a temperate climate as opposed to a colder North Atlantic climate. Colin went on to explain that the first European settlers arrived on this beautiful island back in the 1600s, and a lot of their early buildings were wood-framed. But as we all know from the three little pigs, straw and wood aren't the most robust materials. For almost 100 years, people did a stick-and-frame construction, and then after a couple of hurricanes in 1712, 1714, a light bulb went on, and the only thing left standing were stone buildings. And so the whole technology changed, and people started building with native stone. And so stone became a critical part of the island's vernacular. It made for robust walls, and it made use of this plentiful local material.
它刚好在湾流的边缘，所以我们拥有温和的气候，而不是寒冷的北大西洋气候。科林接着解释说，第一批欧洲定居者早在17世纪就来到了这个美丽的岛屿，他们早期的许多建筑都是木结构。但正如我们从三只小猪的故事中所知，稻草和木头并不是最坚固的材料。近100年来，人们一直在做木棍框架结构，然后在1712年和1714年的几场飓风之后，人们恍然大悟，唯一屹立不倒的是石质建筑。于是整个技术改变了，人们开始用本地石头建造。因此，石头成了岛上乡土建筑的关键部分。它造就了坚固的墙壁，并利用了这种丰富的本地材料。
And these stone walls were in turn topped with heavy stone roofs, which have a noticeably steep slope, a slope which serves a vital function in a hurricane. It turns out that a shallow roof can really suck during a tropical storm. While a steep roof, well, I'll just let Colin explain it. It doesn't suffer suction, which is the big problem in a hurricane. As the wind goes rushing over a roof, if the roof has a lower, pitch, it acts as a wing, and you have lift. And many buildings are torn apart, not by the wind pushing it, but the suction forces that collect on the other side of the roof. So these
这些石墙反过来又覆上了厚重的石屋顶，屋顶有明显陡峭的斜坡，这个斜坡在飓风中起着至关重要的作用。事实证明，平缓的屋顶在热带风暴中真的很糟糕。而陡峭的屋顶，嗯，我还是让科林来解释吧。它不会遭受吸力，这是飓风中的大问题。当风呼啸着掠过屋顶时，如果屋顶的坡度较低，它就会起到机翼的作用，你就会产生升力。许多建筑被撕裂，不是因为风推它，而是因为聚集在屋顶另一侧的吸力。所以这些
slightly higher pitched roofs here in Bermuda also act to create enough turbulence that they break the suction forces and they stay intact. So the roof pitch helps, but the most distinctive part of these rooftops visually isn't the slope. It's the way overlapping stone slats make the sides of each roof look like a bright white staircase. And this style of Bermuda roof serves a purpose related to another feature of the island's climate. And what this does is it slows the water down. As the water hits the roof, instead of going rushing down on a flat plain surface, it has to go down a step. So while the overall pitch of the roof is steep, that's offset by this staircase shape, which keeps water from running down and off the sides too
百慕大屋顶的坡度稍微高一些，也能产生足够的湍流，从而打破吸力并保持结构完整。所以屋顶坡度有帮助，但这些屋顶在视觉上最独特的并非斜坡，而是重叠的石板让屋顶两侧看起来像明亮的白色阶梯。这种百慕大屋顶的风格服务于一个与该岛气候特征相关的目的。这样做是为了减缓水流。当雨水击中屋顶时，它不是顺着平坦的表面冲下来，而是必须走下一个台阶。因此，虽然屋顶的总坡度很陡，但这种阶梯状的形状抵消了这一点，防止水流过快地顺着两侧流下。
quickly. Almost like a little river going through pebbles and the like. So it slows the water down so you can capture the water at the gutter level and you're not losing it over the edge of the eaves. Catching water has been an essential function of houses in Bermuda almost since the beginning. And that was important because the homes did not have wells or any type of common water distribution systems. So we capture the rainwater for our potable water. And this got started in 1612 or thereabouts, just because there was insufficient water on the island available through wells and the like. Early settlers also came up with a clever way to top off these rues, a coating of white lime.
几乎就像小河穿过鹅卵石一样。所以它减缓了水流，这样你就可以在排水沟的高度收集雨水，而不会让水从屋檐边缘流失。几乎从一开始，收集雨水就一直是百慕大房屋必不可少的功能。这很重要，因为房屋没有水井或任何类型的公共供水系统。因此，我们收集雨水作为饮用水。这一切始于1612年前后，仅仅是因为岛上通过水井等方式可获得的水量不足。早期的定居者还想出了一个巧妙的方法来给这些屋顶加顶，即涂上一层白石灰。
This bright finish helped keep houses cool by reflecting sunlight, while the lime helped purify incoming water. Of course, for this whole clever water collection system to work, it has to rain. Thankfully, the island's rainfall is generally pretty consistent. But not always. We've certainly seen the last couple of years where you go two months or almost three months without any reasonable rainfall. To help hedge these dry spells, a typical Bermuda home can store an astonishing amount of water. Houses today will carry anywhere from 12,000 to 40,000 gallons of water.
这种明亮的饰面通过反射阳光有助于保持房屋凉爽，而石灰有助于净化引入的水。当然，要使这个巧妙的集水系统发挥作用，必须下雨。幸好，该岛的降雨量通常相当稳定。但并非总是如此。我们当然经历过过去几年里两三个月都没有合理降雨的情况。为了应对这些干旱期，一栋典型的百慕大住宅可以储存惊人的水量。如今的房屋可以储存12,000到40,000加仑的水。
Every house has its own water pump and pressure system. Why that's important, especially in a hurricane-prone zone such as Bermuda, is that in the instance of a loss of power, you can still get fresh water because every house is self-sustaining. This combination of self-sufficiency and the durability of local architecture helps the island bounce back incredibly fast from even major weather events. We don't appear to suffer the amount of damage you see in some of the other islands and the coastal parts of the United States in the post-hurican event. In Bermuda, after a major event, the island has generally had lights on ready to go
每栋房子都有自己的水泵和压力系统。这之所以重要，特别是在百慕大这样易受飓风袭击的地区，是因为在断电的情况下，你仍然可以获得淡水，因为每栋房子都是自给自足的。这种自给自足与当地建筑的耐用性的结合，帮助该岛甚至从重大的天气事件中以惊人的速度恢复过来。在飓风过后的事件中，我们似乎没有遭受你在其他一些岛屿和美国沿海地区看到的那种程度的破坏。在百慕大，重大事件过后，全岛通常在24或36小时内就能恢复供电并准备就绪。
within 24 or 36 hours. And that's all well and good for the residents of Bermuda. But Cullen is rightfully insistent that these local solutions have global applications, too. The approach to conserve water and to use those resources, again, is going to be critical for the years going forward as a strategy for communities, which are going to have seasonal droughts. As we know, we're all going into a global warming condition. White roofs reflect heat that makes sense. There should be no dark roofs in America. We should all be doing that. It's just simple science. I couldn't agree more. Architects would do well to study tried and tested vernacular solutions like these. and not just from Bermuda, but from around the world.
对于百慕大居民来说，这一切都很好。但柯伦理直气壮地坚持认为，这些地方解决方案也有全球应用价值。节约用水和利用这些资源的策略，对于未来几年面临季节性干旱的社区来说，将是至关重要的。众所周知，我们都将进入全球变暖的环境中。白屋顶反射热量，这说得通。美国不应该有黑屋顶。我们都应该这样做。这只是简单的科学。我完全同意。建筑师们最好研究一下像这样经过时间考验的本土解决方案，不仅来自百慕大，而且来自世界各地。
A Bermuda roof is only white sometimes. In the reflection of the sky, there's a luminosity that happens. So the roofs are not static white. They shimmer white. And it's the interplay of light and darkness on the roofs and in the architecture that I find the most satisfying of the whole lot. To see the subtleties, you have to stand and watch it for just for a little bit, and then you go, oh, oh, that's nice. That's great. Living in an ocean environment, this little park in the middle of the great blue sea is spectacular.
百慕大屋顶有时只是白色的。在天空的反射下，会产生一种光Luminosity。因此，屋顶不是静态的白色。它们闪烁着白光。正是屋顶和建筑中光与暗的相互作用，让我觉得整个事情中最令人满意。要看到这些微妙之处，你必须站着看一会儿，然后你会说，哦，哦，真不错。太棒了。生活在海洋环境中，大海中央的这个小公园真是壮观。
And as a living human being, one wonders why we're here. I think in Bermuda you can almost figure it out. I'm that close sometimes. More from our unofficial, 99% Invisible City expanded audio edition after the break. At the beginning of the 99% Invisible City book, Kurt and I included two short chapters meant to set the stage for the four main ones. Dubbed conspicuous and inconspicuous, these contain stories examining aspects of cities that are either so obvious or so subtle that we tend to overlook them. First up, conspicuous. A few years ago, I produced a piece titled Train Set, which, you guessed it, was all about trains.
作为一个活生生的人，人们不禁会想我们为什么在这里。我想在百慕大你几乎可以弄明白。有时我离得那么近。休息过后，我们将为您带来更多来自我们非官方的《99%隐形城市》扩展音频版的内容。在《99%隐形城市》一书的开头，柯特和我收录了两个短章，旨在为四个主要章节铺垫。被称为显眼和不显眼，这些章节包含的故事探讨了城市的各个方面，这些方面要么太明显，要么太微妙，以至于我们往往会忽略它们。首先是显眼。几年前，我制作了一件名为“火车模型”的作品，正如你所猜到的，它完全关于火车。
And we had so much fun with that, that we produced two more train-themed episodes that expanded our scope to include train cars that are conspicuously static, not on rails, but permanent, embedded fixtures of our built environment. Attention passengers. Food service has now begun. in the dining car. As a building type, diners are striking, the long and thin with chrome accents and rounded corners. Inside their narrow spaces, there's just enough room to walk through and sit down.
我们玩得很开心，以至于我们又制作了两集以火车为主题的剧集，将我们的视野扩大到包括那些明显静态的、不在铁轨上但永久嵌入我们建造环境中的固定装置的火车车厢。旅客注意。餐车餐饮服务现已开始。作为一种建筑类型，餐车引人注目，又长又薄，带有镀铬装饰和圆角。在它们狭窄的空间里，刚好有足够的空间穿行和坐下。
In a built world of taller and deeper structures made with stone and brick and steel and glass, diners are kind of strange, but if you understand where they come from, all their curious design features suddenly make a lot more sense. diners are an evolution of dining cars you know the ones found on trains it's not just their name and aesthetic that traces back to railways many diners were prefabricated as modular units and specifically designed to be taken by truck or train to their final destination hence the long and narrow layout entrepreneur jerry o mahoney is widely credited with coming up with the diner as it is and building the first one in nineteen thirteen His creations evolved to have that now distinctive diner look, long and narrow, sleek, and curvy with flashy chrome accents.
在一个由石头、砖块、钢铁和玻璃制成的更高更深的建筑世界里，餐车有点奇怪，但如果你了解它们的来源，它们所有奇怪的设计特征突然变得更有意义了。餐车是火车上发现的餐车的演变，你知道的，就是火车上的那些。不仅它们的名字和美学可以追溯到铁路，许多餐车都是作为模块化单元预制的，并且专门设计用于通过卡车或火车运送到最终目的地，因此布局又长又窄。企业家杰瑞·奥马尼被广泛认为构思了现在的餐车并在1913年建造了第一辆。他的创造不断演变，拥有了现在独特的餐车外观：又长又窄、线条流畅、曲线优美且带有耀眼的镀铬装饰。
Many vintage prefab diners came complete with counters, stools, tile floors, even restrooms, and they were just transported to the destination, and they got hooked up to on-site utilities. In some cases, actual dining cars were also converted into freestanding diners, and in other cases, diners are simply made to look like classic prefabs for that nostalgic appeal. Which, by the way, totally works on me. Finally, as you probably know, we have an annual tradition here at 99% Invisible. At the end of the year, we gather up short, many stories from various producers. And some of these stories are shorter than others, like this one, a sweet and simple little solo about an inconspicuous way-finding system in New York City's Central Park.
许多复古的预制餐车配备齐全，包括柜台、高脚凳、瓷砖地板甚至洗手间，它们只是被运送到目的地，然后连接到现场公用设施上。在某些情况下，实际的餐车也被改造成独立的餐车，而在其他情况下，餐车只是为了怀旧而制作得像经典的预制件。顺便说一句，这对我完全管用。最后，正如你可能知道的那样，我们99% Invisible每年都有一个传统。在年底，我们收集来自各个制作人的短小精悍的故事。其中一些故事比其他的更短，比如这个，一个关于纽约中央公园一个不显眼的寻路系统甜蜜而简单的小独奏。
One of the stories that came over the transom via Twitter this year is about the four-digit codes on the lampposts in Central Park in New York City. So each lamppost in the park has a four-digit number on it. The first two digits represent the closest cross-street to the post in the 840-acre city park. So if the first two digits are 96, the post is parallel to 96th Street. The second two digits represent two things, which side the lamp post is on and its relative distance from the edge. If it is an even number, then it's on the east side of the park. So e-even-east, that's how I remember that.
今年通过Twitter传过来的故事之一是关于纽约市中央公园路灯杆上的四位代码。因此，公园里的每个路灯杆上都有一个四位数。前两位数字代表公园里离该杆最近的十字街道，公园占地840英亩。因此，如果前两位数字是96，则该灯杆与96街平行。后两位数字代表两件事：灯杆在哪一侧以及它与边缘的相对距离。如果是偶数，那么它在公园的东侧。所以e-even-east，这就是我记住的方法。
And an odd number means that that light is closer to the west side. The smaller the number, the closer it is to the edge. So for example, 9605 is roughly parallel to 96th Street, and it's pretty close to the west side. because it has a small, odd number. But if a lamp post is numbered 9642, it's closer to the east side than it is the west side. But because it has that high number of 42, it's more towards the middle of the park.
奇数意味着这盏灯更靠近西侧。数字越小，它离边缘越近。例如，9605大致与96街平行，并且离西侧很近，因为它是一个小的奇数。但是，如果灯杆编号为9642，它比西侧更靠近东侧。但因为它有42这个高数字，它更偏向公园的中间。
So if you ever get lost in Central Park, find a lamp post, read the emboss number, and you'll know roughly where you are. When the explanation for this code found people on the internet, a lot of people were intrigued by it, but they often wondered, what good is this cool wayfinding method if nobody knows about it?
因此，如果你在中央公园迷路了，找一根路灯杆，读取浮雕编号，你就会大致知道自己在哪里。当这个代码的解释在互联网上被人发现时，很多人对此很感兴趣，但他们经常想，如果没人知道这个酷炫的寻路方法，它有什么用呢？
Well, the answer is, it's not really wayfinding for us, for patrons of the park. It's really for park employees whose job it is to replace and repair those lamps. Now that you know, you could, like, spin around with a blindfold on, set off in any direction, find a lamp, and know where you are in Central Park, which is pretty cool. And if you love little design stories like that, you're going to find a little design stories like that, you're going to find a lot more when you page through your copy of the 99% Invisible City or listen to the audiobook narrated by our very own Roman Mars. So head to 99PI.org slash book and pick up your preferred format.
好吧，答案是，这并不是真正给我们这些公园常客准备的寻路方式。它实际上是给公园员工准备的，他们的工作是更换和修理这些路灯。现在你知道了，你可以像蒙上眼睛转圈，朝任何方向出发，找到一盏灯，就知道你在中央公园的什么位置，这非常酷。如果你喜欢这样的小设计故事，当你翻阅你的《99%隐形城市》或听由我们自己的罗曼·马尔斯叙述的有声书时，你会发现更多这样的小设计故事。所以前往99PI.org斜杠book并挑选你喜欢的格式。
Meanwhile, for more 99PI stories like those you heard today, be sure to check out the full episodes that Kurt mentioned, starting with Highways 101, then War, Famine, Pestulence, and Design, followed by 5440 or Fight, as well as 99% vernacular and train sets. And finally, our annual mini-stories volumes, which you cannot miss because we're right in the middle of them right now. You can buy links to all those aforementioned episodes
同时，想了解更多你今天听到的99PI故事，请务必查看柯特提到的完整剧集，从公路101开始，然后是战争、饥荒、瘟疫和设计，接着是5440或战斗，以及99%本土风情和火车模型。最后，我们每年的迷你故事合集，你绝对不能错过，因为我们现在正处于其中。你可以在本周的网络伴侣99PI.org上购买所有这些提到的剧集的链接
in this week's web companion at 99PI.org. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Roman Mars and me, Kurt Colstead, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, and music by Swan Real. Roman Mars is our host. Kathy, too, is our executive producer. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. the rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, and Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lasha Madan, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason,
99% Invisible本周由罗曼·马尔斯和我（柯特·科尔斯特德）制作，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，天鹅真实音乐。罗曼·马尔斯是我们的主持人。凯西·杜是我们的执行制片人。德兰尼·霍尔是我们的资深编辑。其余团队包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉沙·马丹、约瑟夫·罗森伯格、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森、
Tallinn, and Rain Stradley, and me, Kirk Colstead. The 99% Invisible Logo was created by Stephen Lawrence. We are part of the Serious X-M podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
塔林、雷恩·斯特勒德和我（柯特·科尔斯特德）。99% Invisible标志由斯蒂芬·劳伦斯创作。我们是SiriXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在美丽的上奥克兰潘多拉大楼北面六个街区。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们的新Discord服务器。那里有链接，以及99PI的每一个过往剧集，网址是99PI.org。本剧集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。